قال مسؤول امريكي للجزيره يخطط لارسال
الطائرات حربيه من طراز اي عشره الى الشرق
الاوسط وكان صحيفه
ستنقل مقاتلات حديثه من الشرق الاوسط الى
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ واوروبا في خطوه
تعتبر جزءا من خطوه او من خطه اوسع الهدف
منها تعزيز جهود واشنطن لردع كل من روسيا
والص
[موسيقى]
ين
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا نناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه ما هي دوافع قرار واشنطن
استبدال طائراتها الحديثه بالشرق الاوسط
باخرى قديمه من طراز اي 10 في سياق
التطورات الراهنه بالمنطقه وهل من اسباب
غير معلنه لهذه الخطوه
هل في ذلك ما يؤشر على حاله انسحاب
للولايات المتحده من المنطقه ام هي مجرد
اجراء تكتيكيه لغايات وظروف تتعلق بالصراع
مع روسيا والتصعيد مع الصين وكيف ينظر
حلفاء واشنطن الى هذه الخطوه وما هي
انعكاساتها على خارطه التحالفات والصراعات
في الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
هي مرحله وصفتها صحيفه
بالانتقاليه التي يمر بها الجيش الامريكي
عنوانها الكبير هو التنافس مع كل من روسيا
والصين تنافس تتحسب الولايات المتحده
لامكانيه اي تحول عند منعطف ما الى مواجهه
وهو ما جعلها ومن قبل ذلك تفكر في تقليص
وجودها العسكريه في الشرق الاوسط لكنها
كانت في كل مره تتحلى بالتريث الصحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤول كبير في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه قوله ان القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه التي تشرفها على العمليات
بالشرق الاوسط حددت انها في حاجتنا الى
سربين ونصف من المقاتلات الجويه بالمنطقه
الصحيفه اضافه ان الخطه السريه تقضي
بالابقاء على سفينتين او ثلاث سفر متمركزه
بالشرق الاوسط دون ان تكون بينها حامله
طائرات كما تنص الخطه على الاحتفاظ
بواحدتين عسكريتين تضم كل واحده منها اربع
بطاريات وكذلك الاحتفاظ بثلاثين الف
جنديين امريكي في الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع يضم الينا من عمان
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي وسيكون معنا ضيوف اخرون
بطبيعه الحال لكن ارحب ايضا بالدكتور خليل
العداني ضيفنا من
واشنطن
ابدا باللواء فايز الدويري لواء فايز
طائرات عتيقه امريكيه طائرات هجوميه ليس
لا تسمى طائرات مقاتله وانما تسمى طائرات
هجوميه
ستنضم الى الشرق الاوسط بدل عوضا عن
الطائرات الحديثه الموجوده في الشرق
الاوسط كالاف 15 والاف 16 وغيرها ماذا
يعني ذلك
لوجود القوات الامريكيه الجويه في الشرق
الاوسط
يعني في البدايه دعني اشير الى نقطه اولا
يوجد تسع قيادات رئيسيه مركزيه امريكيه
جميعها في هيكلها التنظيمي يوجد قوات على
الارض
باستثناء القياده المركزيه الوسطى يوجد
هيكل تنظيمي للقياده تجمع لها القوات حسب
المهام التي ستناط بها واضرب مثال في عام
التسعين عندما تم غزو الكويت تم تجميع
500000 مقاتل
الغالبيه العظمى من امريكا في عام 2003 تم
تجميع 130 الف مقاتل اذا دعني اقول في
البدايه القياده المركزيه لا يوجد لها في
الهيكل التنظيمي قوات باستثناء وهذا ما
يختلف عن البقيه الان نذهب لماذا هذا
التغيير اولا كانت الظروف في لحظات معينه
يتم الحديث عن الضربه لايران والضربه
لايران اخذ وضع لها عده سيناريوهات تعتمد
على الطائرات على الصواريخ الكروس توماهوك
وما شابه ذلك الان هناك تحول خلال الفتره
القريبه جدا مما يخفض من وتيره التصعيد
فيما بين السعوديه
وايران وهذا مؤشر ايجابي قد يساعد على
استغلال
بعيدا عن دوافع هذا القرار وجود هذه
الطائرات في الشرق الاوسط بدل الاف 16
ماذا يعني من الناحيه العسكريه من ناحيه
الوجود الجوي الامريكي
هذه الطائره هذه الطائره
اول تجربه الها في عام 72 من القرن الماضي
واول دخول للخدمه في عام 78 كان عليها
نقاشات داعمه ونقاشات معارضه ولكنها تسمى
طائره الدعم القريب او الاسناد الجوي
القريب او قانصه الدروع والدبابات
وبطاريات الصواريخ فبالتالي هذه الطائره
لها ادوار محدده الان لننظر الى الاقليم
ما هي التهديدات التي تواجه القوات
الامريكيه او تواجه المنطقه معظمها يتمثل
في الخطر الايراني والذي يقتصر على طائرات
مسيره وصواريخ ولا على اي اي على سلاح جو
فاعل في الجانب الايراني اذا هنا يمكن
يمكن احلال الطائره ايتن بدل الاف 15
وهناك كان في قاعده الظفره في فتره من
الفترات طائرات حفت 22
واف 35 الشبحيه اذا دعني اقول هو الموقف
التقدير تقدير الموقف الاستراتيجي لسخونه
المناطق هناك ثلاثه مناطق تقدمت على الشرق
الاوسط من حيث سخونه الموقف اولا في شرق
اوروبا ثانيا بحر الصين الجنوبي ثالثا
كوريا الشماليه واصبح الشرق الاوسط في
المرتبه الرابعه طيب الدكتور خليل العناني
حسب
فان هذا التفكير تفكير في تخفيض احلال
الطائرات القديمه محل الطائرات الحديثه في
الشرق الاوسط هي خطه قديمه
ما الذي دعا بها ان تجد
نفسها موضع التنفيذ الان الكلام عن عن
ابريل يعني ايام وسيتم اخلاء منطقه الشرق
الاوسط من الطائرات الحديثه وتحل محل هذه
الطائرات القديمه
[موسيقى]
الخاصه بيتكلم على اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
وتايوان بان هناك دعم امريكي بشكل او اخر
بان هناك وجود امريكي عسكري متقدم ومحاوله
لردع الخطر الصيني فيما منطقه وايضا الخطر
الروسي ليس فقط
تتمثل في اعاده التموضع الاستراتيجي فيما
يتعلق بالسرعات العالميه بمعنى اخر كما
قال اللواء فايزه الدوري ليس هناك التركيز
اكثر على الاوسط حاليا هناك تركيز اكثر
على مناطق اخرى اكثر التهابا واكثر هناك
التغير في الاولويات الامن القومي
الامريكي ايضا مع حديث امريكي سواء كان
رئيس الاركان او وزير الدفاع عن انه هنالك
خطر ايراني وان ايران امامها اسابيع على
ان تصبح قوه نوويه وقال انها اولويه يعني
كيف يمكن ان نفهم ان الشرق الاوسط تتقلص
اهميته في ظل هذه التصريحات المتتاليه من
الج انب الامريكيين عن الخطر الايراني
الذي يزداد في رايهم واصبح اولويه كذلك
انا اعتقد انه ما يحدث الان ليس انسحاب
امريكا المنطقه العربيه ومساله ما يسمى
باعاده مواضع استراتيجي بمعنى اخر هناك
محاوله
للتعاطي مع الاخطار في المنطقه العربيه
بمنظور مختلف عن منظور القديم في القديم
كانت اكثر على بيطلق عليه الحروب غير
التقليديه مكافحه جماعات المطرفه بايران
تحديدا هناك الان حديث متواصل حول امكانيه
احتواء ايران من خلال المفاوضات نعم هناك
امكانيه على الطاوله وقبل حوالي شهرين الى
الان هناك كانت هناك مناورات عسكريه
اسرائيليه امريكيه ثم يتعلق بسيناريو
محاكاه لامكانيه ضرب ايران لكن بشكل عام
امريكا تفضل استخدام الخيار التفاوضي فيما
يتعلق بالحل بازمه الازمه الايرانيه
وبالتالي هناك توجه هذا الاطار الامر
الثاني متعلق بان هناك قناعه امريكيه
بالاعتماد اكثر على الحلفاء الاقليميين
فيما يتعلق بالخطر الايراني بمعنى اخر
هناك محاوله امريكيه لاعطاء مسؤوليه اكبر
حلفاء الاقليميين بمساله دمج اسرائيل في
المنطقه العربيه ونعلم جميع الخزينه هناك
سعي حميم من قبل اداره بايدن لدمج اسرائيل
فيما يتعلق بالهيكل الامن الجديد في
المنطقه العربيه وبالتالي تلعب اسرائيل
دور مهم جدا رومي ليس استبدال طبعا الدور
الامريكي لكن بشكل او باخر محاوله اعطاء
ضمانات امنيه
اسرائيل في منطقه الخليج العربي وهنا نصل
للسؤال للدكتور فايز الدويري اللواء فايز
الدويري من عمان يعني هذه هذه الامور التي
تحدث عن الدكتور خليل وايضا
يعني فيما يبدو انه ليس عدم يعني
تقليل من الاهميه للشرق الاوسط وانما
تصعيد للاولويات الاخرى لكن
انتشار هذه الطائرات محل الطائرات الحديثه
هل يمكن ان يغير اي معادلات في الشرق
الاوسط هل يمكن ان يخلي باي موازين للقوه
تحسبها الاداره امريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
تحدثت في البدايه وقلت لك بان القياده
المركزيه الوسطى هي القياده الوحيده التي
يوجد فقط
مخطط تنظيمي هيكلي للقياده انما بقيه
المتطلبات الميدانيه والحقيقيه تجمع حسب
المهام وضربت لك مثالين اي بمعنى اخر اي
تصعيد في الشرق الاوسط
يستدعي جلب قوات سواء كانت قوات بريه قوات
بحريه قوات جويه يتم تجميع ذلك في اطار ما
يسمى المسافه والوقت لان هذا هو التنظيم
وبالتالي دعنا نقول بان ما يوجد في شرق
اسيا تقريبا 330 الف جندي 53 سفينه رئيسيه
اكثر من 30 غواصه منها عشرين نوويه دعني
اقول
قوه ولكن هذا سلاح ردع
وتحضير استراتيجي في السياق الاستراتيجي
لارسال رساله حازمي الى الصين ان لا تزود
روسيا وان لا تهاجم
وبالتالي هذه هي حركه قوات حسب مقتضيات
الموقف الاستراتيجي العام للجيش الامريكي
تراجعت حده الخطوره في الشرق الاوسط لا
مانع من نقل هذه الطائرات ازدادت الخطوره
في الشرق الاوسط تعود قسم منها خلال 24
ساعه قواعدها موجوده تسليحها موجود
مستودعات موجوده
دكتور خليل هذه الخطه كانت سريه
وحتى تفاصيله حتى الان سريه هل هل تقول
واشنطن كل شيء فيما يتعلق بهذه الخطوه
لا اعتقد ذلك بالطبع هناك جزء سري متعلق
بمحاوله تهدئه اي مخاوف من حلفائك في
المنطقه العربيه خاصه ان هناك اعتماد شبه
كامل عفوا هناك اعتماد شبه كامل الحلفاء
امريكا في المنطقه العربيه على السلاح
الامريكي فيما يتعلق برضع اي مخاطر سواء
مخطط متعلقه متعلقه بالتنظيمات المضرفه
وبالتالي هناك بالفعل او هناك بالتاكيد
اجزاء غير معلنه حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن ايضا
كما قلت قبل قليل هناك محاوله امريكيه
لاعاده تموضع استراتيجي في المنطقه
العربيه وانا يخطى من يظن ان هناك انسحاب
امريكي بالمعنى الحقيقي بنتكلم على قواعد
عسكريه امريكيه موجوده في الخليج العربي
موجوده في الامارات وفي قطر وفي الكويت
وفي العراق وفي البحرين مقر الاسطول
الخامس الامريكي موجود في البحرين مقال
الاسطول السادس موجود في ايطاليا بيشرف
على منطقه البحر المتوسط واوروبا وافريقيا
وبالتالي هناك تواجد امريكا عسكري بالفعل
هناك اكثر من كما قلت قبل قليل هناك وجود
صواريخ او منظومات صواريخ دفاع الجوي
باتريوت موجوده هناك سفينتين حربيتين على
الاقل طبعا الطائرات يعني يتم استدعائها
في اي وقت وهنا الازمه وبالتالي هناك تعود
امريكا هناك عدد تموضع متعلق بحاله
السيوله العالميه والتغير في نمط العلاقات
الدوليه فيما يتعلق بالنمط الصراعي
المهيمن الان الصراع اللي موجود حاليا
الحرب الطاحنه الدائره على مدار اكثر من
عام الان في روسيا تمثل تهديد ليس فقط
لاوكرانيا تهديد للغرب بشكل عام وهناك
الشعور بعد هذه الحرب تطول اليوم هناك
تصريح للامين العام لحلف يقول نتوقع
استمرار الحرب لفتره لفتره طويله وبالتالي
هناك استعاده امريكا لهذه المساله ايضا
الصراع مع الصين اصبح صناعه على اشد
وراينا وقرانا قبل اربعه شهور ان الخطر
الرئيسي في استراتيجيه الامن القوام
الامريكي الجديده متعلق بمحاوله احتواء
الصين وهناك الشعور فقط مجرد قوه اقتصاديه
ما رايناه من الصين خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
يشرب ان هناك دور سياسي للصين راينا وساطه
صينيه فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات السعوديه
الايرانيه نسمح حاليا وساطه صينيه او
محاوله للتواصل في الحرب القرانيه هناك
تمدد اقتصادي صيني هناك تمدد عسكري هناك
محاوله امريكيه لتاجير رساله قابله للصين
بان هناك ردع من خلال وجود قوات مستواه
تماما فيما يتعلق بالصراع مع الصين
الاشارات الامريكيه في الواقع ذات الابعاد
الاستراتيجيه تتوالى وخصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالخلافات العميقه مع الصين وروسيا وفي
بعضها ما يقرا بين سطوره عسكريا وسياسيا
وزير الدفاع الامريكي قال في جديد هذه
التصريحات ان على ما بعد الحرب البارده
ولا وهناك منافسه شديده شديده لتحديد ما
سياتي بعد ذلك اوستن اضاف زياره الرئيس
الصيني الى روسيا ارسلت اشاره مقلقه
للغايه وهنا نعود الى الشرق الاوسط مره
اخرى والى فايز الدويري يعني من الواضح
صحيح الدكتور خليل يقول انه ليست حاله
انسحابه امريكي لكن من الواضح انه
الاهتمام الامريكي بالمعارك الكبرى او
بالصراع الاكبر مع الصين ومع روسيا
ينتج عنه بالضروره انسحب امريكي من الشرق
الاوسط والا يعني كيف يمكن تفسير انه حتى
حاملات الط ائرات لم تعد موجوده في الشرق
الاوسط يمكن استدعائها نعم لكن كم من
الوقت تستغرق اذا نشب صراع ما في الشرق
الاوسط كم من الوقت تستغرق مثل هذه
الحاملات ان تصل الى المنطقه
يا سيدي يعني اولا اذا ابحرت من امريكا
تحتاج الى 14 يوم حتى تصل الى بحر العرب
اي حرب
كمحلل استراتيجي اي حرب له
اشاراته ورسائله
التمهيديه او الاولى
وبالتالي شراره لا يمكن ان تنطلق الحرب
خلال ثواني لابد من ايماءات تستطيع
القيادات
الامنيه السي اي ايه
وغيرها من التقاط هذه الاشارات واعاده
بناء القوه امريكا لن تنسحب من الشرق
الاوسط هناك ثلاثه مناطق منطقه الشرق
الاوسط منطقه شرق اسيا بحر الصين الجنوبي
هذه المناطق هناك وجود امريكي في هذه
المناطق الثلاث ولا يمكن لها ان تنسحب من
اي منها لكن اهميه هذه المناطق تختلف من
وقت لاخر الان على المنطقه الوسطى منطقه
البحر الاصفر البحر الصيني الشرقي بح
الجنوبي بدات تطغى من حيث الاهميه
والخطوره والسخونه على اهميه الشرق الاوسط
واهميه شرق اسيا لماذا لانه هناك مؤشرات
لدى صانع القرار الامريكي اولا منطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي هذه تعتبر مياه دوليه من
خلال الجزر الصناعيه تحاول الصين ان
تحولها الى منطقه صينيه اقتصاديه خاصه
ماذا يعني ذلك يوجد بها اهم مرين في
العالم ممر ملك ممر تايوان يوجد بها تسع
مليارات برميل نفط يوجد بها 22 مليون
تريليون متر مكعب من الغاز الان اذا اصبحت
منطقه اقتصاديه خاصه الصين استغنت عن كل
انواع الطاقه ولا بل ستفرض
واجور مرور
من ممر ملقه وممر تايما لهذا ارتفعت اهميه
البحر الصيني الجنوبي على حساب شرق اسيا
والشرق الاوسط لكن لا يعلي التخلي عن
الشرق الاوسط او شرق اسيا طيب هذه هذه
الطائرات التي ستنسحب من الشرق الاوسط الى
هذه المنطقه منطقه العمليات في في المحيط
الهادئ والهندي
الوفائز هل ستضيف الكثير في هذه المعركه
لا انا يعني اعتبرها تقع في اطار ارسال
رسائل اكثر منه تغيير حقيقي لماذا يوجد
2923 طائره امريكيه مقاتله
الاسطول السابع هو الاسطول الرئيسي في
الاساطير الامريكيه اي قوه تاتي الى منطقه
وهو مسؤول عن منطقه مساحه مليون و600 الف
كيلو متر مربع حتى في حال انتقاله لمنطقه
عمليات اسطول اخر هو يتولى القياده يوجد
ثلاث حاملات طائرات بصوره مستمره يوجد 330
الف جندي القوه الضاربه الامريكيه
كما تفضلت دكتور خليل العناني بالنسبه
للشرق الاوسط حلفاء الولايات المتحده كيف
يمكن ان يتعاملوا مع هذه الخطوه هل
يتعاملوا معها بحذر
بقلق ام انها خطوه عاديه لا تمثل اي تغيير
استراتيجي في المعادله في الشرق الاوسط
انا اعتقد ان هناك قناعه لدى معظم حلفائك
في المنطقه العربيه بان هناك حاجه لعاده
موضع في المنطقه العربيه ايضا بمعنى اخر
هناك شعور خليجي تحديدا النهوض من الصعب
الاعتماد باعتبارها حليفه استراتيجيا وهذا
الامر واضح بشكل كبير جدا بعد الانسحاب
الكارثي الامريكي من افغانستان الذي ادى
الى حاله فوضى عارمه ولم يكن هناك تنسيق
كبير مع الدول الحلفاء الخاص حلفاء الدول
في حلف النيتو وبالتالي هناك الشعور عرض
متزايد خاصه خليجي من الصعب ان يتم
الاعتبار فقط على القطب الامريكي باعتباره
حاميا لهذه الدول هناك الان محاوله للتوسع
شرقا وراينا ذلك هناك يعني انفتاح بشكل او
باخر على الصين وعلى روسيا هناك علاقات
متطوره بين السعوديه بين الصين هناك قمه
صينيه عربيه غير مسبوقه في الرياض قبل
حوالي
اربعه اشهر من الان شهور من الان
في السعوديه هناك ايضا قناعه بان هناك
حاجه لتبريد الملفات الساخنه وراينا على
سبيل المثال استئناف العلاقات الايرانيه
السعوديه راينا استئناف الامريكيه المصريه
التركيه هناك زيارات رسميه بين الطرفين
راينا محاوله تهدئه المخاوف في المنطقه
العربيه
هناك قناعه ايضا هناك الشعور عربي بان هو
انا الاوان كي يتم التعاطي باعتبارها
حليفا لكن ليس حليفا واحدا فقط هناك
محاوله الاستخدام ربما معادله الحرب
البارده المناوره بين القطبين للحاليين
الصين من جهه وامريكا هناك حاجه لعاده
تموضع ايضا تناسب المنطقه العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
الدوليه ونشكر من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر كل عام وانتم بخير وفي امان
الله
[موسيقى]